i would actually encourage all of you  you know if at some point in your life  you know you have to work with people  where you feel a bit insecure  like that's essential because that means  you're working with people who are  better than you and who are pushing you  right and uh so always encourage if you  if you actually feel very secure in what  you do  uh you know that means you're doing  something comfortable and you're not  pushing yourself and so  uh there are many many times i felt uh  working with people in a group  am i doing enough are these people seem  much better than me and i think i think  that's a  inherent part of learning